When I sleep,
I dream.
And in my dream, someone wants my crown.
There is God...
and there are the Peaky Blinders.
People think that I'm gonna fall.
Who's gonna take the throne, eh?
We have never even heard of your people.
So we are not afraid of your threats.
They said that Tommy Shelby
was a spent force,
that he was spent in the head.
Three,
two,
one.
Bang.
So, Tommy Shelby, it's war you want,
it's war you shall have.
There will be a war,
and one of you will die,
but which one, I cannot tell.
Mr. Shelby, you've come to my attention.
I will have need of men like you,
except there is no other man like you.
Sometimes killing is a kindness.
It will be Tommy Shelby who's crucified,
and there will be no resurrection.
We own the ropes.
Who's gonna hang us now?
No one is gonna hang you, Tommy.
You're gonna hang yourself.
Do you have some kind of death wish,
Mr. Shelby?
Nothing can stop us.
Now you've heard of us.